this video is sponsored by babel there
is all kinds of alcohol molecules out
there in nature and they all do
different things for example methanol is
used in racing fuel propanol is what's
in rubbing alcohol and ethanol is the
alcohol you drink in alcoholic beverages
this simple two carbon atom with a
hydroxyl group attached does so many
things to your body when you drink it
but first a word from our sponsor babel
babel is the number one language
learning app in the world it's different
from your typical language app they
don't rely on an ai to make hand
exercises their lessons are written by
real language instructors who go the
extra mile to craft practical
conversations using culture slang and
traditions to develop real world
interactions i live in upstate new york
not too far from montreal so when i
visit i use babel to brush up on my
french save
got it awesome sessions are in short
10-minute interactions so you can
practice whenever you have a few minutes
throughout the day if you click the link
in the description below you can get 65
off your babble subscription and a
20-day money-back guarantee check out
babel today you may have noticed after a
few drinks that trips to the bathroom
become more frequent among the many
things that ethanol does to your body
one of them is inhibiting a hormone
called anti-diuretic hormone or adh adh
is responsible for telling your body to
reabsorb water back into the body after
the kidneys have filtered blood of waste
products your cells make a lot of waste
like creatinine and urea which are both
toxic to the body these waste products
have to get removed and your kidneys are
the organ for the job when blood flows
through the kidneys it passes through
its filtration system made up of a
network of vessels called nephrons in
the nephron blood flows through a group
of capillaries called the glomerulus
where waste products are filtered
through a very small tubule called
bowman's capsule clean blood flows back
into the body and waste flows through
the nephron into the bladder and is
excreted as urine now your blood is not
some advanced ai that knows not to
filter out water from blood it filters
out whatever passes through the kidneys
whether it be waste or water red blood
cells though don't get filtered because
they're too big to fit so how do you
retain water if it all gets lost through
your kidneys this is where adh or
anti-diuretic hormone comes in to
reabsorb water filtered out of the
kidneys the pituitary gland releases adh
which stimulates your kidneys to
reabsorb water back into the blood
essentially adh prevents you from peeing
out all the water in your body when you
drink alcohol ethanol blocks the release
of adh in the pituitary gland so your
kidneys are not signaled to reabsorb
water back into the blood and you end up
excreting a large amount of it in your
urine this can become very dangerous as
you could get dehydrated since your body
is not retaining any water in fact when
you're hungover you feel like garbage
because you did not drink enough water
and you fell asleep in a dehydrated
state if you drink a glass of water with
each alcoholic beverage you won't get
dehydrated all alcohol whether it's
spirits wine or beer will make you
excrete water but of the three beer
makes you pee the most but why is that
though beer has a lower alcohol
concentration than liquor and wine it
has more volume per drink than liquor or
wine does beer comes in 8 12 and 16 oz
containers and that's a lot of water
paired with alcohol which is a recipe
for plenty of trips to the bathroom